well brian as the state faces new cases
and that highest number of daily deaths
you mentioned there are
71. doctors are really hoping that those
who have recovered from the virus step
up now to help others who are still
fighting it 8 news now reporter madison
kimbrough was in our newsroom tonight
with more on how convalescent plasma is
saving lives
madison yes it's true convalescent
plasma contains antibodies that can
recognize and neutralize the virus
but with the lack of people donating
hospitals and doctors
are concerned as the vaccine continues
to roll out in nevada
doctors are turning to the community for
help in treating patients
using convalescent plasma it's taken
from people who have recovered from
covet 19
it contains antibodies that can fight
off the virus
giving plasma isn't dangerous
it's a safe it essentially is a blood
donation
and this is a way you can really help
patients
and protect and potentially even save
someone's life
alan diskin the executive director of
the red cross here in las vegas
endured his own personal struggle with
covid he recalls hearing the news for
the first time
and i still get chills when i think
about when they first told me that i
thought
how can i get sick i mean i was as safe
as you could possibly be
um but you never know where it'll come i
remember the nurse coming in
and she was holding a bag and it was a
you know maybe a quarter of the way full
and it was a translucent liquid
and i immediately knew that it was
convalescent plasma
the blood transfusion worked for diskin
he was sent home after 48
hours and now he urges those that feel
healthy after contracting the virus
to donate or call 100 red cross or
red cross blood.org book an appointment
to donate blood
if you have the antibodies for
convalescent plasma
you are likely going to give somebody
the opportunity
to save their life and if you are a
survivor of covet 19 and want to donate
the red cross isn't the only place that
you can go there are several blood
donation facilities across the valley
reporting in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now